Evet
evet Herkese merhabalar
kronometreyi başlatalım Malum bu tekme
sesi süreden dolayı çok sıkıntılı bir o
yüzden hızlı konuşursam durdurma
şansımız yok bu 18 dakika içinde ne
kadar çok kelime söyleyebilir sen o
kadar çok söylemeye çalışacağım bir
cumartesi günü bu Gencecik insanların
attığı büyük adımlar için buraya
geldiğiniz için Hepinize çok teşekkür
ediyorum Öncelikle Kayhan Karlı
öğretmenin bir köy okulu öğretmenin
çocuğuyum hayata gözlerini Ardeşen'de
yukarıda yaylada bir köy okulunun
lojmanında açmışım babamın ilk
öğretmenlik yaptığı yere İşte o zaman
küçük adımlar vardı geçenlerde bir
arkadaşımla konuşurken onu anlattım
ilkokul yıllarımda Babam bir 40 bin
kişilik bir kasabada bu bu müdürü
olmuştu en büyük hayalim bir gün
İstanbul'a gidip İstanbul'da yaşamak
tıbık Sonra işte zaman geldi neler oldu
Şu anda da 50'den fazla ülkede
Öğretmenlerle anne babalarla ve
gençlerle çalışıyorum
öğretmenlerin mesleki gelişme anne
babalık eğitimimi eğitici
sosyal girişim Her şeyden önce kendime
bir sözün vardı 40 yaşında kimsenin
bordosu da olmayacağım diye kırk yaşına
girdiğim zaman dedi kullanımda
yöneticiydi burada bir tek yine
şey olan ortaklığı paylaştığı olan Bir
yerdeyiz Selçuk Pehlivanoğlu dedi ki
deli misin de 40 yaşında dedi bırakılır
mı kariyer işlemde tek kariyeri Bence
hiçbirisi sırtında yük olduğu sürece
kariyer değildir 40 yaşında bıraktım
sonrasında
bıraktıktan Kısa bir süre sonra Garanti
Bankası'nın o zaman ki siyosu Ergün abi
Ergün Özen'den
bu sefer it veya ulaşıp 15 milyon
dolarlık bir bağış aldık ve onunla
öğretmen Akademisi Vakfı'nı kurduk
öğretmen Akademisi Vakfı yoluyla da
Yaklaşık 300 bin öğretmeni Türkiye'nin
her tarafında Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı
yaptığımız protokolle iki buçuk günlük
atölye çalışmalarıyla 20 yüzyıl
becerileri konusunda gelişimlerini
hizmet ettik 2013'te kendi sosyal
gelişimlerini kurmaya başladım Şu anda
da sosyal girişim okullarımız var
dijital okullarımız var yükler çek
okullarımız var ama Bizi biz yapan en
önemli şey
sürdürülebilirlik kavramının altına
yükledik her şeyi ne yapıyoruz nereye
gidiyoruz diye soruyoruz bu temaya
gelince bütün Bunun hepsini
ben ilk duyduğum zaman Arkadaşlar daha
çağırdıkları zaman
çok güzel bir temel edip Çünkü biz niye
eğitim yapıyoruz sorusuna cevap verdim
Aslında temel hikaye bu niye eğitimi
yapıyorum sorusuna Belki çok kişi o
kendi cevabı verecektin ama
başlığı da koyarken Ee dedi çocuklar
bize benim ekipteki genç arkadaşlar öyle
dedi ee hocam Hani Çünkü bir önceki
bakın küçük ayaklar için büyük adımlar
dedik arkasından bizim ekipte kilerdeki
Ee hocam Ne anlatacaksınız Bir de böyle
bir film var bir kitap var ya yeter
kitabı var falan Google yapıyorlar
çocuklar her şeyi aynı şey çıkıyor bütün
sonra üzerine çıkıyor eminim dedik
çekimi de burada Onu araştırmışlardır ve
Hoca ne anlatacak orada bir de arkamdan
kırıldılar ile Bize bir slayt gönderin
slayt gönder Dün gece 12'de geldi galiba
ki de ben de Eğer cevap verdim sevgili
izleyenler
bizim Ebeveynler Eğitimciler olarak önce
şunu anlamamız lazım beni ben yapan
eğitim-iş olarak hayatımı değiştiren en
temel kabulü Milton ilk sonun bir
kabulüdür bir söylemidir ünlü psikolog
psikiyatrist
çok önemli Bu ip noter App is built on
Alexander ki her insan tam ve bütündür
hiç kimsenin tamir edilmeye ihtiyacı
yoktur
Her insan tam ve bütündür hiç kimsenin
tamir edilmeye ihtiyacı yoktur Oysa Biz
büyükler
anneler babalar öğretmenler bütün
çocuklara bozukmuş gibi davranıyoruz
sürekli düzeltmeye çalışıyoruz sürekli
düzeltmeye çalışıyor Bunlar bozuk hatta
biz okullarda tamirhaneye benzettik
anası babası getiriyor biz bu yaptık Ama
bu bozuk sağlam çıkmadı Alın siz bunu
düzeltir diye getiriyoruz buraya sonra
düzelmiş olarak yer aldığımız iddia
ediyoruz beğenmezsek yedek parça eksik
koymuşsun özel okul sahibi diye bazıları
geri iade etmeye geliyor lan orada onu
yapamayınca bu sefer diyor ki buna bir
de test yaptır arada tost isim
üniversite düzeltsin bari üniversite hiç
düzeltemiyor Çocukların hepsi İşsiz
güçsüz ortada geçiyor Yok be ne oldu
çünkü hikaye Sanayi Devrimi'nin bize
yutturmaya acısıydı o Ama bu eğitim
tamamıyla sanal Gerçekçi olmayan
çocuklara zarar veren bunun da çocuğun
duasına naturası aykırı olduğunun
farkına varmak zorundayız
geriye dönüp geriye dönüp Kadim gelenek
de insanım nasıl bebek yetiştirdi Nasıl
evlat yetiştirdiği sorusunun cevabını
bulmak lazım Bu dört tane temel beceriyi
Eğer doğduğu andan itibaren bir insan
evladı geliştirmiyor sabunun adına alkol
yeni ev okulu değil Doğa Okulu değil
normal Okulu değil Ne dersiniz iyi
anne-baba ve Eğitimciler Eğer siz
çocuğunuza ya doğduğu andan itibaren
Azim dediğiniz beceriyi kazandırmıyor
sanız Eğer üzgünüm ama sizin çocuğunuzun
ileride özgüvenle ilgili çok sorun
olacak Hiçbir okulda bozukluğu tedavi
ödenecek hiçbir okul tedavi ben seni
Azim hikayesi birazdan bu sahnede
konuşacak Berkay burda Önde oturuyor ben
Berkay yedi sekiz yaşından beri tanırım
şimdi ralli pilotu biraz da O konuşacak
O zamandan bu yana da yeni gördüm
öğrencim sayılıp Yani aynı de
lokasyonlardaki beraberdik onun o
yaştaki azmine ve babasının ona verdiği
ailesinin ona verdiği azim ve
kararlılığa şahit olduk Ben
zannediyordum ki sekiz yaşında kartın
yapıyordu deli gibi çalışıyordu okulda
olduğundan daha fazla ofisler deydi Ya
ben hani öğretmeniz ya şöyle geliyordu
ya çocuğa Yazık ediyorlar Ya şurada iki
soru çözdüm seyler Yarın LGS var ya bu
çocuğunda bu anası babası caklı başında
değiller Onlar ne dediler falan diye
geçiyordu içimden bakın işte aradan
geçmiş 15 sene Berkay bu saatte de az
sonra niye
ona küçük yaştan itibaren çok çok zor
bir spor yapıyor Bu arada dünyanın en
zor en ağır en çok ihmal yapılması
gereken en tehlikeli işlerden birebir
Bir de bu şey zannediyor kadar pahalı
bir spor yani sponsor bulunması
gerekiyor birilerini ikna etmesi gerekir
Bu buraya çıkmak kolay iş değil onun
için orada Ne yapıyor Yanında birazdan
arkaya gitti galiba Hamza var o Ne
okudun Universal Ne iş yapıyorsun ben
youtuber olacağım diyor için kırıyorum
Oğlum niye okutun O zaman onu hali bozuk
düz başka bir şey çıkmış bak yani bunu
okul yapmamış anne baba da yapmamış
Çocuklar kendi kendilerini tamir
etmişler
Aslında sorun şu çocuklar bozuk değildi
çocuklar düzgündür Biz okullarda bozmaya
çalıştık Ben diyorum ki modern okula
size verdiğimiz çocukları bozmayın sağ
salim gelin yeter belki mecburen okula
gönderiyorum Sağ Salim Azim geliştirin
iki çeviklik
şehitlikten kastımız şu çok önemli
çocuklarınızın erken yaştan itibaren
düşünme Çelikli Aslında zihinsel
çevikliğini geliştire biliyor musun
sorusunun cevabı Neden biliyor musunuz
bu oturun önce bir kaç kişiyle
konuşuyorduk O nedenle Bakın ben 55
yaşındayım çok az önce Hayat hikayesinin
kısa bir bölümünü anlattım 55 yaşında
Hayata bir köy Okulu'nda ışığın dahi
olmadığı lambaların olduğu köy
okullarına başlamış birisiydim tarım
toplumu gördüm bahçede sabahlarla
tarlaları sürenleri gördüm Bu sağladığı
o yaşta herkes var tarım toplumu gördüm
Sanayi toplumunu gördüm daha sonra
kentleşme bütün hepsini Bilişim toplumu
gördüm şu anda her şeyi Kolumdan
yönetebiliyorum diyebilir teknolojilerle
öyle bir yere geldim 55 yıl içerisinde
hayatıma kaç yüzyıldır
ve 55 yıl içerisinde hayatıma Örneğin
şöyle bir şey söyleyeyim salonda
Muhtemelen şuna ilgili birşeyler olacak
Dünya nüfusu Google yaparsanız daha
sonra yapın Tabii Dünya nüfusunun ne
olduğu sorusu ile ilgili bir şey sorsam
hemen cevabı dedim kaç kişidir yaklaşık
diye Dünya nüfusu yaklaşık 9 milyar a
geliyor şu anda
2012-2013 yıllarında Ben dijital
bilgelik yolculuğu diye bir konferans
serisi yapıyordum o yıllarda Dünya
nüfusu henüz da altı altı buçuk milyar
the
iyi bakın katmanları ve Sen şöyle
sorsana Yarın soru Sizde kalsın Sonra
bakın acaba Dünya nüfusu yeryüzündeki
insan nüfusu ne zaman bir milyara açtı
kaç bin yıllık İnsanlık tarihi var 1
milyar insan hangi tarihte oldu acaba
Bu sözü kapalıdan geçelim Ben size
söyleyeyim bir 1800'lerde
o kadar binyılda milyar nüfusa gelmeyen
insan
nüfusu 1800'lerde milyar geçip
2000'lerde 10 lira doğru gidiyor
ya Bu ne demek biliyor musun şunlardan
olacağım burada bir öğretmen olarak
Birazdan yine sahnede göreceksiniz Bu ne
demek biliyor musunuz dünyada sahip
olduğumuz doğal kaynaklara yetmeyecek
kadar biz varız
biz yetmeyecek kadar biz Bizim Türkümüz
Yani insan türü var ve bu tür hızla
kendi yaşayacağı alanı yok ediyor
Karıncalar gibi çeker gibiyiz bakın
Birleşmiş Milletler'in gelecek
hedeflerine bakıyoruz 21 gelecek hedefin
içerisinde en çok kullandığımız şey
sürdürülebilirlik yanında Sürdürülebilir
Gıda ve Tarım politikaları köyleri
boşalttık Çiftçi yok ettik çocuklar
çiftçiliği sevmiyor domatesin tohumu
bile yok elimizde işte ne olsun
çocuklarınız bu kadar kısa sürede hızlı
değişmeler yaşayacaklar çok hızlı O
yüzden zihinsel Çelikli ihtiyaç var Ben
20 sene boyunca mühendis olmayı hayal
ettim öyle bir dünya yok artık yirmi
senelik bir hayal kuracağım bir dünya
yok Üç senelik beslenir hayallerimiz var
daha kısaldı O çok hızla değiştiririz o
zaman Şevik bir düşünme biçimini
ihtiyacımız var ya benim gibi bu kilo
ile çeviklik nasıl olurdu şurdan olacak
Burada sorun yok yani her ne kadar kilo
da olsa bir diğeri özyönetim
Fiat
Panda ve sırasında yaklaşık iki yıllık
uzaktan eğitim sürecinde anne babaların
çoğu isyan etti ya böyle eğitimi olur
uzaktan eğitim olmazmış zaten sen 2011
yılında yazdığı bir kitapta dijital
bilgelik yolculuğu için öğrenme
Yoldaşlığı diye bir kitap yazmıştım
orada şöyle tarif etmiştim yakın
Gelecekte bu fiziksel avmlerde
ihtiyacınız olmayacak Bunlar sadece
sergileme yerleri haline dönebilir ya da
başka bir şey çünkü gelişen teknoloji
size hologram larınız yoluyla gittiğiniz
her yerden uzaktan alışveriş yapıp Hatta
öğrenmeyi bile ol gamınız yoluyla
yapabilecek hale doğru geliyorsunuz
demiştim bugün salgında birlikte
karşımıza şu çıktı salgında yaptığımız
değerli dostlar salgını yaptığımız iş
uzaktan eğitim değildi salgında
yaptığımız zorun neydi
Ben bir okula gittim okul
öğretmenleriyle çalışın daha doğru bir
şey istediler onlarla ilgili
becerilerini geliştirmek için
öğretmenlerin o arada iki yılın
arasındaki yaz tatili dönemde sordum
hocaların nasıl yapıyorsun Tekrar Hocam
biz hiç konuşmadık Nasıl yani her sabah
sekiz buçukta der savaşlar gibi çocuklar
bilgisayar başına geçiyorlar bir şey
açıyorlar Zoom açıyorlar Biz de
oturuyoruz E peki çocuklar kıyafetleri
de gidiyorlar gömlekleri kravatlar hepsi
takılı Alt tarafı görmüyorlar Allah'tan
çocuklar oturuyor aynı hocam 10 dakika
teneffüs 50 dakika ders 10 dakika
teneffüs 10 dakikadır Öğlen yemeği arası
veriyoruz akşam günde dokuz saat ders
yapıyoruz aynı yaptık vallahi dedi dedim
o zaman Siz ne yaptınız kokulu ama
belirler böyle istiyoruz hem de diye
çünkü dokuz Varsa para veriyoruz dedi
İyi de seni yüzenin motivasyonu ile
potansiyelleri fiziksel kaldırabilir
dili öğretmeni motivasyonu Senin o kadar
saat onun orada oturması ergonomisi ona
bir şey öğrettiğim zannediyorsun dedim
ki ben size çalışamam Kusura bakmayın
yönet ve diğer böyle eğitim yapacaksın
bensiz geliştirmem yapmadım Ne yapayım
ben senin gel burada bir kere Şey Bozuk
zemin bozuk Yani bu zeminde top
oynamıyor bunun içinde Öz yönetimini
geliştirip kendini yönetip karar
alabilen çocuklar olmadığını da gördük
orada salgında ne yaptınız şey vardı
çocuklar çok iyi Özen iyi özelliklerini
çocuklar şuydu Öğretmen arkadaşlara
söylüyorum
kendisinin fotoğrafını alıp o cam
ekmeğimde oldu Ekranımda oldu
fotoğrafını koyuyor kendisi yak doğru
3'üncü sınıf öğrencisi Biz burada bir
tanesi ekranında oldu diye fotoğrafını
koyuyorlar orada şeye Zoom arka
Planlarında çocuklar videolar
yerleştirdiler Ders yapıyormuş gibi o
Anladım öğretmen bir bakayım ya bu bizim
yaptığımız canlı Dert değil başka bir
şey var orada bunların hepsini
yapamazlar o çocuklara bayılıyorum o
çocukların hepsinden acayip çıkacak hiç
dedim bizim okulda bu çocuklar hepsini
aynı iş yaptıralım simitle Çünkü onlar
küçücük ay en büyük adımlar atıyorlar
kendisini yönetiyor ve en önemli bir
diğer beceriyle bakalım azim çeviklik
özyönetim ve uygulama Çünkü bu Çağa çok
hızlı akıyor çok hızlı değiştiniz içinde
uyumlanmak zorundayız bakın Biz
öğretmenleri iki sene zorunlu okul
sahiplerine Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı iki
senelik süreçte uyumlandırma dıkdık
Çünkü biz ihtiyacımız bizde bu
becerilerde yok Bakın bu kuşak Biz
Anadolu Lisesi sınav kuşağız Hadi 50'li
yaşlar bize çalıştırdılar bir iyi
Anadolu Lisesi Kazan Fen Lisesi kazanan
onu yaptık çalış bilgi üniversite Kazan
onu yaptık 25 lira çalış emekli ol Ben
emekli oldum Hala çalışıyor
olmadı oradaymış Yani sonunda bakın
durup patladı artık şu gençlerin
hiçbirine Mesela bu okuldaki
öğrencilerin hiçbirisini emeklilik
hayali yok kimse sormuyor çocuklar
emeklilik nedir umurlarında bile değil
ama biz hala annesi babası olarak
Diyoruz ki hocam ya filan üniversiteyi
kazansın diyor iyi bir gelecek o emekli
olsun ya Sevgili anne baba o senin
gerçekten çocuğun gerçekliği değil artık
bak çocuklarınızla kurduğunuz ilişki
için bütün yetişkinlere aynı şeyi
söylemek istiyorum
gene bir deli gurubuyla çalışıyoruz
Miller dediler ki hocam sizin
söylediğiniz gibi söylüyoruz Biz de
çocuklarımıza Ama siz yaptığın zaman
değişiyor lar yapıyorlar Biz yaparız biz
söylediğin zaman olmuyor Ben aynı şeyi
söyledim
duyduklarından değil yaptıklarından
Ya sen söylüyorsun yapmıyorsun Çünkü sen
sadece söylüyorsun Söylediğin içinde
yapılacağını da böyle bir dünya yok
çocuklar Sizin söylediklerinizi
yapmazlar çocuklar sizin yaptıklarınızı
yaparlar çok basit değil ki
ya
hani şey var ya Türkçede bir deyim var
imamın dediği diye söylediği yaptığı
gibi yapıyor bak orada milaslı yapılan
önemli olduğunu görüyoruz O değil de
bile görüyoruz orada belki erken yılsın
çok önemli bir şey söylüyor
çocuğunuza bırakabileceğiniz en büyük
servet sürdürülebilirlik için
servet sahip olduğu ile mutlu olmasını
öğrenmesi tatmin olması bu çağdaki en
ciddi problemlerimiz den bir tanesi bu
çocuklar çok hızlı tükettikleri için
tatmin sorunları var o da bitti o da
bitti o da bitti o da bitti tablet
alıyorsunuz üç gün sonra daha iyisi
gelsin Öbürü alıyorsun üç gün sonra daha
iyi geldim o zaman neyi öğretmeye
ihtiyacınız var o Sen kendine yeten de
yaşamayı öğrenmesi lazım Biz okulda şunu
özellikle çocuklarla çalışıyoruz
Anaokulundan itibaren herhangi bir şey
cep atacak sa Şu soruyu soruyor bunun
son kullanımı
cevabını kendisiyle Evet son kullanma
kimin için benim için Peki başkaları
için son kullanım olmayabilir mi Evet
Örneğin kediler için son kullanım
olmayabilir onlara da hali Tamam o zaman
bunu şuraya ayırıyorum bunu kedilere
mama yapılacak olan bölüme gidiyor veya
bir kıyafetini değiştirecek
dolabında 8 tane aynı tipte şey var hem
neyi var Bunları zaten senede bir defa
giymiş Belki belki üç senedir giymedi
dolabında duruyor zaten yeni bir şey
almak için oradan bir tanesini eksiltmek
zorundasın gibi bir ülke yönetiyoruz
yeni bir şey alacaksan çocukluğundan
itibaren annelerimiz babalarımız da şu
diyoruz yeni bir şeye ihtiyacın varsa 3
ayakkabım var yeni ayakkabı da almak
istiyorsun peki hangisine vazgeçeceksin
var ama ne yapıyoruz modern kültürlü
için vazgeçmiyoruz sonra ne ayakkabıya
yerimiz kalıyor ve gömleğe yerimiz
kalıyor ama bunların hiçbirisini çocuğa
faydası yok Çünkü siz onu tüketim
tuzağında büyüyorsunuz hal ki neye
ihtiyacımız var üreten bir topluma
ihtiyacımız var üretmek için tüketim
bilincine sahip olması gerekir orada
dönüştürülmesi gerekir orada bunu
öğretmek gerekir orada Mevlana diyor ki
Konyalı olduğum için belki Mevlana'dan
söz etmeden Geçemiyorum öyle ana çok
güzel bir şey söylüyor bakın gözlerine
bakar Gönül oraya kar gönülleri yakan
ayaklar oraya kaşarsiz Nereye bakarsanız
ayaklarınız oraya gitsin ayaklarınızın
gittiği yerde çocuklarınız koşa koşa
küçük adımlarla Sizinle gelsin ve
yetişkinlere öğretmenler bir okulda bir
dönem öğretmenler de çalışıyorum okulun
karakteri çok ilginçtir mesela çok uzun
yıllar okullarda akreditasyon yaptığım
için söyle bu yaklaşık bir kaç saat
okulda sadece bulunduğum anda okulla
ilgili yorumlarım gelir bir okulda
çalışmaya başladık okulun şeyi komşu
temsilcisi sizin gibi okutacağım Kusura
bakmayın şey değil vardı Türkiye'de bir
okul değil yurt dışında Yunanistan'da
bir okulda dedi ki bizim okulda de
fiziksel şartları nedeniyle dedi çok
gürültülü okul dedi Nasıl yapacağınız
gürültü hissediyorsunuz Ya rahatsız
oluyor bu acayip gürültülü
bu dedi şey okulun fiziksel şartları ise
açık tavan var mı bende var buradan Ben
sadece bir şey söyledim yürüttüğü
olmasının nedeni yetişkinler o kadar
bağırarak konuşuyorlar ki
koridorun bir ucundan bir öğretmen
öbürüne bağırarak sesleniyorlar
öbürü çocuklarla bağırarak konuşuyor Bir
de sınıflar kapılar dersler açık
tamamıyla açık okul kendi gürültüsü
üretiyor Dolayısıyla öğretmenlerin
bağırarak konuştuğu yerde sakin ki bu
soru soran birlikte olan bir şey bulamaz
mümkün değil bunu tekrar alacağız Şerif
özet 19 dakika olmuş Geleceklermiş Zaten
buradan sonrasında ise
hayat yolculuğu benim Ardeşen'de bir
köyden Harvard'da dokuz yüksek sans
yapmaya arkasından Doktor yapmaya kadar
hepsine götürdü Ama ben bu hayatta bir
şey öğrendim Bir çocuğun çocuk olduğunu
Kabul ettiğim andan itibaren gerçekten
bir Yetişkin olduğunu
hissettin çocuklar bozuk değildir Aksine
o küçük adımlarla kocaman küçük
ayaklarla kocaman adımlar atıyorlar koca
bir hayat inşa ediyorlar Yapmamız
gereken tek şey bir televizyon dediği
gibi her insan tam ve bütündür hiç
kimsenin tamir edilmeye ihtiyacı yoktur
Onun da bir birey olduğunu ve o bireyin
kendi geleceğini Eşim çok söyler
insansan sınıf arkadaşım Her çocuğun
kendi 3D tayin etme hakkı vardır
ve her çocuğun kendi geleceğini tayin
etme hakkı vardır sorun kendinize
çocuğunuzun kendi geleceğini tayin etme
fırsatı veriyor musunuz teşekkür ederim
o